well ladies and gentlemen it's Wednesday
we have got Skylar Astin he was frying
an egg just 40 minutes ago and then he
talked me goes bro can I go to my jungle
show and I went show so bad one-man show
so bad please don't be anxious I'm bad
and then you're like well I said get it
here yeah get here now I have to poo I
haven't dying shut up you said shut it
here shut up and get here hold it get
here and we'll throw you on well throw
you a bone well throw you bought her I
feel like maybe he's throwing us suppose
he walks he misses a [ __ ] his cool
hat that's great wear when you're happy
in the dogs if you're an artist you wear
that huh yeah
hey he's an artist I want that hat and
then he's kind of like a guys it's like
he's all loose so just oh sorry guys
been shooting with Nick Nolte well I've
been shooting in Bulgaria Bulgaria and
playing hard play in New York and then
let me do it let me do a commercial let
me use your equipment and do a you mind
if I do a voiceover before we start then
I try to give them some direction
because I don't nobody gives me
direction yeah that's a fair point ok so
then I gave you guys both life direction
and here we are it's been a while man
it's been far too long way too long I
have a faves I've only done
I've only sang in this studio for the
big brown breakdown intro I have any
guests classic hit a boredom and it's I
tune charm that's a Ginsu you skylar
astin collab and how about you song it
at my very first stand-up solo ever live
that was funny I just feel like I'm so
loyal I'm such a good friend
I need a litter this is no bulls I
wouldn't do that for you I haven't no
definitely not and I can't sing yeah but
also just like as far as you know
getting back to me timely I always get
back you do but it's always like sorry
man can't or or no you will you'll be
like hey can you do the podcast three
minutes ago and I'm like hey man I'm in
Eastern Europe yeah very considerate hey
no no I I love you we upon out more at
box and burn we've had a lot of
off-air conversations that a ton would
love to hear so I recorded it and we're
being recorded
what would my podcast be called behind
the velvet curtain yeah I like that card
behind you know yes I'm gonna say
unaware I like talking to you and your
brother cuz you guys are such mm a fan
oh yeah but you out you're also in the
know so it's good to keep my ear to the
grindstone cuz you guys we've come from
a fan's perspective but you guys know
the game we've really we've really come
full circle too because we we started as
just straight-up fans you know and then
I got a little bit known for some
projects and then Dana took a liking to
me and that's how I met Chris for the
first time and now now like I'm about to
turn 30 Chris Chris is gonna be at my
you know like birthday dinner he's at my
wedding I think for them when I'm when
I'm it's in New York in the West Village
you want to come yeah we're rich as [ __ ]
we will fly this private September 23rd
guys either
sorry I'm a Tempe [ __ ] somewhere
probably I'm doing Saturday I'm doing
this Canelo breakdown it's a post-race
down you move it to Madison Wisconsin
guys it took us two years to get here
today let's just this is great that
happened did you cry when your boy Chris
Weidman won his fight I was so happy man
where was I I think I was you know I go
the fight it was in well I didn't I
didn't it was in Long Island but I it
was like the 28th or the 22nd or
something I just wrapped graves and I
had like five days to put my [ __ ] in my
suitcase with my wife before like moving
to New York until December and I'm there
now and I'm only back for five days
because I'm in between things so you're
going straight from here and then going
to New York and then I'll be there till
December I'm literally here to see if
the house is still up and to like get a
bunch of winter [ __ ] and take stuff
honestly do the podcast that's why I
wanted to squeeze it in and I just got
back last night so I I'm like five
like you know finally got groceries it's
like the morning I make breakfast I'm
frying an egg and I'm like well let me
like see what my Thursday is doing cuz I
have all these plans to do stuff today
and you're like get here now the only
time and Here I am perfect and I look
really great I agree I look great no I
got this hat in the village thank you
for asking
I know we didn't make sense there's only
one of them guys it's a vintage thing
come on it's not like you could get it
there's a lot since you've been shooting
an Albuquerque great yeah now Bulgaria
training twice a day at Jacksons are
they make you clean the mats how's that
work yeah I just applied John with the
steroids I don't yeah hey that's it
hasn't been oh yeah it's been proved
it's the hey about that sample that be
sampling coming in scorching hot it's a
grass I think's Phoenix huh how does
that work what is a beef sample
something hit me
so the a sample so they always take so
you piss in two jars yes there's a and B
sample so the a1 they do right away they
test and the b1 they test later right
with more intricate testing yeah but
when those things get flagged
especially the B sample it's got there's
so much stringent testing it's not like
yeah you know like I see how my
Instagram people I know who knows bro
you know he could have been he could
have been it could've been taint it so
we gave him his Gatorade no no stop stop
stop what if he was on one leg dude that
might do that [ __ ] with stuff like you
do like taking nyquil I tested hot now
let's stop do that I see bagels can
sometimes yeah everyone like and I get
it man I wish there was an excuse I wish
there's some way we could navigate
through this but now it's just a [ __ ] up
that's that's the bottom I was actually
spending a lot you know Brandon six-gun
Gibson's a really good friend another
guy at my wedding the same night that
Overeem thoughts deep a like greg
jackson was like there will be millions
of title fights there will only be one
of Skylar's wedding you should go so he
like yeah and then over him lost you
know I'm so sorry what is what does you
know what I mean when I fall probably
probably your fault why the calm six-gun
I actually know this answer is it's just
cuz he's fast I think it seems like he's
got six hands coming at Dickey's code he
used to he is really quick we want
went in New Mexico to Johnny Tapia's
boxing gym which was super super fun and
like super old-school before after he
done
after but now it's just run by like og
dudes who was like Johnny Tapia is uncle
like still there just like 500 pounds
being like you guys are returning or he
tells six-gun that he had a turnover his
punches and say but 600 the most humble
human being so of course he's like you
know I know normally like anyone would
be like do you [ __ ] know who I am man
I trained John Jones and Carlos Condit
you know but he's like oh yeah show me
and he's like the dirt you could learn
something from anyone so you're around
the Jackson guys like John Jones well
there might there might there might
there might there like somewhat of my
social circle went on there I go home
what's the last time you conversation
John I you know John was super busy in
camp and he is his own private thing but
actually my last night like one of my
last weeks in Albuquerque I was like six
gone I'm worried I'm working till the
bitter end you're approaching 214 right
now we're probably not gonna be able to
see each other till I leave so I had
this break in my day where I was able to
come and he's like Hobbiton I'm with
bones until 5:30 and then I go to the
ranch to go with cowboy and so I was
like dude I'll just go just to say
goodbye also maybe I'll sneak in a
couple of like watching John Jones right
now this could be fun and I didn't see I
haven't seen John because I like you
know it's hard
schedules are crazy anyway I I do shoot
a show for 16 hours a day too so yeah
I'm generally there always and and
everyone's like once a week I'll see Six
Gun so I go there and John being John is
is thirty minutes late so he had just
gotten there and I was in the Octagon
with his jiu-jitsu coach Winkeljohn
six-gun willfox photographer of John
Jones and and John and Izzy I mean it
was just a great group I was like Jesus
I'm like I'm there I mean I mean I'm in
a new part of this yeah and I'm in the
Octagon while they're doing a full-on
six minutes like six round it was his
last day of hard training so you have
like a round where six-gun does all the
funky [ __ ] we go John comes in and just
does like a lot of the basics then they
have one of his training partners go in
and just wrestle the [ __ ] out of him I
mean it was so fun to watch and he was
he was already starting to dye it but he
looked like a monster I mean I was like
I never seen anything like it and I
turned to Will and I was like dude if I
was a betting man I would feel like I'm
a cheater because he's gonna destroy
Daniel Cormier my favorite though of
course he is breaking obviously but he's
like look like she looked like I'd ever
I mean like he looked like my comics
terrible yeah he really did yeah so now
it's just like so sad to talk about in
hindsight because I had this amazing
conversation about legacy and with John
after turning oh yeah yeah we talked for
a while about you know I don't want to
divulge too much because it is he still
is like a friend and it's it's an
uncomfortable situation because I'm a
fan but a friend but it's like are you a
friend where if he needs a loan reach
out to you know we don't like it out
that close we don't like Tara spend
money respect the conversation you had
yeah it was nice but yeah but like not
get that but like we need a place to
stay for four years can he come to LA so
my name your back I'm just saying like
if for four years you'd know where to go
and he can't fight anymore not getting
paid I mean can you bring him and his
four kids and three dogs and his wife to
your crib I was moving I think I'm close
enough to Stephanie McMahon at the WWE
to say hey help this guy make the John
Jones Brock Lesnar thing happen in the
movie do that man [ __ ] that makes sense
what else is he gonna do it let him
train go to the hill take steroids just
like Brock does but let me ask you a
question can he fight in Russia can he
fight at Bellator No so this drives me
nuts when people go oh belters pick him
up he's on a contract no the contracts
nothing the United cannot fight in the
United States they all are under the
same umbrella of commission so he now he
can sign would like to rise in or I
don't think belt or do this but he could
fight in Russia
and Abu Dhabi and Brazil could he fight
like fate or in Japan or some weird [ __ ]
he's also under contract with the UFC
AAA and this is this is not just good
you're suspended by the Commission does
not void your contract you'd have to
have his contract for it well you know
what he won't up my Instagram I own
Bellator rising he's under contract
honestly I
I take a stance I actually have not
taken a stance cuz when do I'd like to
do these kinds of platforms like I like
when I talk to Six Gun about it who's
really as a brother to him it's like at
this point man it's like yeah I'm off
the train you know good it doesn't
matter there was no train right now
there is no train the train has put out
to pasture I care about the guy as a
human being because he really can't get
out of his own way I mean it's really
sad and I'm just hoping that like we
don't see him in rehab or doing awful or
becoming you ever see like the OJ
Simpson [ __ ] six part thing when he
is like yeah so you know like when he's
like at that at all those shitty clubs
and Vegas and doing that [ __ ] and
getting into like weird organized crime
like that that's what I'm hoping that
like he figures out a way to you know
live because no you care about this in a
very human level like you know I'm also
not the tight like when I say I'm after
Jon Jones Trey nice I mean like I can't
rank him pound for pound the greatest
anymore just cuz tarnish yeah cuz it's
not like at his level you just don't
start doing steroids went in the rematch
against DC sure so I'm gonna assume
you've been doing it your entire career
hate to tell everyone listening most
guys are doing some oh yeah but with the
new stringent testing he didn't know the
test so yeah I don't I listen I've
trained with John that guy's an absolute
beast whether he's on peds or not hey
guys you know complete [ __ ] freak I
don't know if he needed it I don't know
what's going on
honestly the best one he just smokes a
joint and goes and does puts it together
or coke the night before or whatever
whatever do but I just so when you know
so yeah as a human being I can I hope
he's alright but um I just
it sucks cuz now what do we do you lost
your biggest starting like heavyweight
division unless your pal
it's over it's over it's like a Michael
Vick situation and I care it is true
really condone it's a weird thing to
make that comparison but just in the
amount of time that it took between like
for like everyone to come back to him
being a professional again like that's
what it's gonna take its gonna take a
solid three years oh it's over it's
different Michael Vick because if three
or four years was the suspension well
the max of before I did the minimum is
gonna get a lifetime ban no right not
lifetime
it won't one thing you can't do there
won't be you know you'll be to for
rights it's leaner defense between two
to four that very least it's too bad the
problem is is when the the worst thing
you do is lie to them when you lie down
then then you get Ito's involved and you
get these people are like [ __ ] you and
then you're make a they're gonna make an
example out of you so I bet at best case
scenario Johnny it's three unless they
find some crazy loophole
his lawyers do work he's got Malik in
there Matthew Kawa that guy's always
trying to like he's that I mean I feel
can't do tainted supplements anymore no
I don't quit playing that game no no no
dick pills I never bought that come up
with some table tonight you know what I
don't think it's gonna change the
outcome but they're gonna come up with
some [ __ ] octa defense know what I would
do if I was John and what I would tell
them to if I was on his team I would go
come straight Street oh that's [ __ ]
great and just asked for forgiveness
you can't ask if I was John like here's
the thing man I got [ __ ] caught we
didn't know this test everyone I've know
is doing the same [ __ ] that you guys are
gonna hate me that's fine I'll be the
bad guy but yeah this is the game I play
man I got caught my bad hmm yeah tainted
supplements those dick pills crazy or
someone put this steroid from the 1960s
in my Gatorade no like we can smell the
[ __ ] from here I was in Havana the
bananas there yeah they have cialis in
them you know I took it on purpose yeah
but yeah it made me want to rip Daniel
Cormier his face off like you know and
then when you're if you're DC it's just
it's just a [ __ ] show you have a now to
no contest right so Daniel Cormier is
now the new or will they do it just a
cream and jam Jimmy Manuel
for the dc's the chant right cuz use the
champ going into sheriff course no no
contest nothing chain course the belt
doesn't change hands so so he'll just
challenge Jimmy man how dare you oh no
because lost no by no time
Asda Maya yeah Volken I didn't know that
Volkman was such a decorated kickboxer
such a high level
kickboxer with the name like Vulcan owes
Damir wouldn't you think that he was a
stand-up special as him but he's what is
his kickboxing record it's something
crazy hold on I know it off I think it's
12 and one there's the no contest there
was a Chechnya arm wrestle that it lost
I don't know his record volcanoes Damir
what I did what what you wants Gustin
but I don't think he's gonna get it no
cue books books well who's next for
Cormier or do you do a number one
contender fight and that Cormier take a
while off that's what you really do yeah
I'll do Gus Finn Versalles to me that's
smart that's the way to do it man we're
never gonna see Gus Jones - I know that
you're never you see you never seen John
rusty pay you never see John was brought
for the World Heavyweight title that's
the bummer they lost that they lost
their stones is three years because
because John Jones is a UFC star conor
mcgregor's now just a star so it's like
you really lost them all
I mean cuz Rhonda's nowhere Cody could
could could could could could with like
three very impressive unbelievable
performances I think he can transcend
it's a little better on the mic and
speaking yeah so he's such a fighter
yeah that comes with that kind of an
Asian experience and I percent cody has
it Kevin Lee has it yeah Kevin Lee does
happen that could be good
oh so hey I got that hot take that I
wanted to talk about Conor McGregor you
know it's really not that hot so what I
want and I know you disagree because I
do listen to the show I think that the
only fight next for him is the Nate
trilogy yeah for the light heavy for the
light lightweight belt you know I think
that it happened sometime early 2018 or
worth the December 30th fight No
so I think maybe March yeah
uh let the dust settle from the
mayweather stuff and then like also
contract me I mean that's that's really
what it's come down to so maybe May
maybe June who knows sometime in 2018 I
wouldn't say January though no and in
the event that Conor and this is a tall
order if he appears to have made
adjustments cardio-wise
if he puts it on Nate in the 4th and
finishes him with like a minute left in
the 4th looking like he's peeking
looking like he's done that McGregor
thing and the whole time he's kind of
talking about the last fight because
it's all they're gonna want to talk
about what happened are you worried
about gassing Nate Diaz is a really
decorated boxer what do you think and he
really does beat Nate Diaz in impressive
fashion that is when he gets on the mic
and pulls Floyd out of retirement for
the second time to win the record and
they do the rematch in 2019 or a New
Year's Eve 2018 I know there's not a
demand for it right now because people
like I don't need to see that fight
again it's never hands over because
tissue you have or and I think you could
get Floyd out because that magnitude of
money I think to be the only thing to do
but I just don't think you didn't get
the same demand from the public eye
unlike saw that like you know Floyd let
it go 10 cuz he bet that you would
finish him in 10th he bet on selfish 10
so I don't think that matter of that
that's that's a fact that he better I
mean I'll say maybe I can believe it
it's hearsay
also I I think the play and then Floyd
would be what 42 yeah but that's the
point so now these are all like factors
that go and well now Floyd's 42 and he
has been retired for now two more years
and that we go over to the club that he
uh I don't think he could do as a tanked
and and I think the ship has sailed
I get it but she I'm seeing that ship
bat what about if he's gonna do what
we're ganna Connie though in that Conor
McGregor organic way where he over he
the way he got no it's different than
the rematch to name totally different
not decided out of retirement GSP will
just be John he's gonna fight he's gonna
fight
he's about back 175 pounds right now as
you saw him going into the elevator the
other day he looks bloated and fights in
November I love his like you'll know if
I ever went up I would do it a proper
way and take two full years to do it but
then all of a sudden he goes in that
elevator and it's just like even just
Big Macs by the way I still think that's
why where did you see him in there abyss
being instagrammed this being Instagram
some thing of them doing press together
and I'm getting an interesting it's like
badge or do you know like do steroids
don't get caught though you know like a
whole little thing by George George and
George is just looking at him like I am
probably going to wrestle you and hold
you down yeah she will problem when I
saw him I saw him cage side just he was
he was coaching who's the guy who was
out of Tristar black guy at this not
this little guy Clem oh yeah front but
you think that was the game jr. Rima
juice ain't so thick he looks so strong
and thick he looked every bit a hundred
ninety pounds at least
oh yeah no he's he's breaking - for sure
yeah big boy and now he's fighting a 185
so I really think like you pulled this
up let's just like talk let's do it talk
about like how much he weighs in this
he's got that distended belly to her
like that extended it's a weird potbelly
kind of thing going on yeah she's very
still has a muscle gut yeah that's an
interesting thing you know it's not this
one it's the one after yeah there it is
boom look at him dude and Bisbing
filming he looks like a bouncer at a
Long Island like at like the Jersey
Shore like I show I love GSP who much
respect but he just lost a huge yeah
it's blurry the spread collars not
helping like my metaphor look at that
that's a weak attempt by this is
terrible and by the way George st.
Pierre left because he wanted a stricter
trust
he's like known for being one of the
only champions that is
Trulli anti and I know some of those
people have I gotta be honest I don't
know anything of course but um if you
look at his body and I know he's very
gifted physically his body looks like
like I don't know when you see guys who
train a lot in mixed martial arts
without steroids they just gonna get
really skinny he was I can't do that you
can't do that you can't just base the
off the I test the biggest freaks I know
your eyes like that yeah a guy no yeah
like I know stuff going on though back
in the day remember when I was like with
his nipples yeah I was like look man I
don't know okay a lot of people were
doing stuff that's all
dude that picture I mean he could
totally be on steroids what are you
talking but of course he could totally
knob you can't do the i test this is why
it doesn't exist it's a void thing I
really go through every UFC fighter and
then have to assume who's on and he's
not chris is no no I'm saying my
boyfriend's aren't but you can argue
that you know yes people go well when
there was no testing use undefeated then
testing comes any search losing mm-hmm I
can do this with every fighter if you
want of course you not say like it
doesn't work of course ma'am but that's
family here watch your tongue god damn
he needed that win goddamn dude came
over if you lost that fight I know it is
interesting that you who've been in the
UFC can I tell you so I'm sorry to cut
you up right but I'm also not sorry at
all um so when Chris when Chris this is
something interesting
Chris recently retweeted something I
haven't talked about it personally with
him but well actually this was when
right when Jones popped there some
random person tweeted like my my 2018
prediction is that Chris Weidman's the
light heavyweight champion with this new
news that's my first thought
right and Chris retweeted it which is
interesting because before he fought
Gastelum there was a lot of talk like I
was even thinking outlaws yeah I was
like we've talked about it right I do
not like a lot of matchups in the top
five for him though at like what's in
scares me for him um or me anyway I like
my you know Cormier I think he matches
up well with Cormier Dustin's a little
bit of a challenge I'm a so big well
with outside
that pose Damir I think you smoke so
stamina good I'm glad to hear you say
that I just don't know I actually don't
know why men but why well apparently he
tosses heavy weights in the gym you know
change of steeper beat pieces mom does
yeah Weidman well you know I've heard
stories about why I mean I would knock
your socks off I've been Saint with big
boy big big boy I'm a complete freak
talk to Matt Serra and Ray Longo about
what he does to steep a or just heavy
weights in general is really as well
you'd as well not not steep a but just
like heavy weights in general you hold
their zone was stupid I think -
absolutely does uh but I like heavy
weight you look at I mean look at light
heavyweight name a bad matchup for I
just wanna get one a light heavyweight
about Daniel Cormier I think I would
love to see I don't drink I wanted to
see him fight Shogun before he fought
gasolin that was my next fight for him
Gus for yeah nothing is the worst
matchup form control wrong our trap I
like Weidman and I'd favor him and
everyone had Jimmy Manuel is a little
scary
good man was very scary power but it's
wrestling you know people you know Chris
is the chrismas wrestling's amazing
striking is very underrated - people
don't realize you say a lot of people
you know think that Chris is mostly a
grappler but he's just phenomenal
wrestling but it's striking sounds good
it's very underrated though it's good I
know I would like to see I wonder what
happened with the whole um I don't yeah
I like him a light heavyweight and
there's no ordinary fresh blood look at
middleweight it's bad it's care who's
top like honestly I think he beats yo
Romero ten nine times out of ten I think
that was a fluke I really do I do
that's a tough matchup he was winning
that fight yeah he's doing well but
still you know Romero
they I mean I happen to believe it they
love Rome they were he was leading and I
think he beats Jacare no way there but
the thing is the tough matchup for a
very light heavyweight I don't see a lot
of tough matchups for well light
heavyweights just you know better cardio
yeah give me quicker
he's not gonna cut as much weight well
good then I'm happy I'm happy to hear
because he I think he didn't want to
have that conversation especially while
he was on the losing streak but it was
just very interesting to see him retweet
that he goes I'll talk about him it's an
ego thing but now they has a win you
know I don't know what they have planned
for him I don't know
the UFC wants I don't know the UFC wants
that I don't know why they wouldn't
swish with John out with John out and
how all of the idle Wyman has a great
story
middleweight divisions being held up by
a lot better way it's a [ __ ] show it
really is
light heavyweight for him would be on
Luke Rockhold I'm excited about that
fight by the way against David branch
I am surprisingly only no I wasn't until
I heard he's just stupid I heard David
branch on aerial show what'd he say he's
just spitting fire it was fantastic it's
been fire and right now I'm Shane with
this guy in New York this is dude Sydney
makuu who who trains with David and this
guy I believe so
but he's just you know I've just been
hearing a lot like lately you know when
you just he keep hearing from people
personally that are like and Harry
stegler who's a wrestling coach over at
Jackson's but he's like more of an
independent contractor and he works
closely with David branch and a lot of
people I go you don't understand this
guy people are overlooking this guy cuz
his last fight at 211 was boring his
[ __ ] it's awful awful awful terrible
awful I was watching a with Harry UFC
jitters I'm like but he found the UFC
like six times with nine now I know but
a champion that world series of fighting
like every way in middleweight but you
know what's interesting the dance bug
really wants this he asked apparently
for this fight like his rock when he
sees my only issue with this fight with
Rocklin is how bad did you want it these
days Rocco ever tell you my Luke
Rockhold losses and their gun that long
it dude
he just looks sad cuz you look at like a
Connor or Nate when they lose or like
dude I was with I was okay so I was at
UFC 199 when he lost to Bisping and it
was the night where Arielle got banned
it was like a crazy night and I was at
my buddy Shannon and and then we we got
back somehow to the press conference
which is was actually crazy if you
remember
Bisping came in with beer it was still
Uriah and Dom's trilogy and that that
the the the the pre-fight excuse me the
post-fight press conference was almost
like the pre-fight press Carlos it was
crazy and I was there and dave meltzer
was there and Mark Raimondi was
they're like dude Ariel got kicked out
what it's like how I found out it's a
crazy night right really surreal because
I'm it's like everything's being taken
down and I'm just like drunk with my
buddy and I'm like let's just walk
around I don't know and I'm walking in
this like random hallway yeah it was in
forum at the forum and we're backstage
feels like I've never seen this face
we're checking but we're checking it out
and in literally as I'm walking down a
hallway just me and my like UCB buddy
Shannon just dana white in his whole
entourage he's coming and he's on the
phone probably with China or something
cuz like the next day the sale was
announced right so he was sitting on
that information and I finally see him
and I'm like dude and I think dude that
post I press conference was crazy and he
was like what and then on my back comes
charging Luke Rockhold Dana dude dude
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] man yeah I need
I know who my god dude I need I need
that back I need I went back you don't
understand like like like I oh my god I
need to fight him right now like I've
never seen he's like I need that rematch
you know well because businessing was
like rubbing it in his face and he got
knocked out and also I think you know
when you go [ __ ] yeah yeah that's what
happens I mean you talk all that [ __ ]
man but I saw a very emotional Luke
Rockhold and and injuries but he's
begging to his boss and Dana's just
doing the like easy man we'll see what
happens it just happened just you know
about that one yeah but Dana's do I want
to see a rematch right away when the
champion is they don't like doing
rematch too many guys immediate rematch
is yeah it's too much
so quite the best part of this story is
that Luke Rockhold knocked out one of my
closest friends really really awfully
like I mean stopped him in a really
vicious way it was Lydon yeah and I
don't like how he talks about Chris just
personally there's a of course but but I
feel it's personal and and it is
personal anjaana's phase so what I did
is I say well I grabbed him by the cut
dick right and I would no no no but this
this car this this story does not end
with
then I stepped on his toe and ran away
he looks at me and he's grabbing me and
he's going right you saw it you were
there you read the post my press
conference like I think right right me
I'm just like yeah yeah yeah yeah and
your brain is like seeing like this
awkward situation where I don't even
know Luke I've never even met him yeah
and Dana's like get the [ __ ] out of here
for a second go home just like well real
talk another time yeah it was just like
a really intense thing to be involved in
I was like wow it's just like those men
the kind of thing I don't maybe I don't
know I never knew Luke to talk that much
trash I do like the way Luke when he
beats like when he beat Bisbing he
helped him up yeah him respect he's a
good like if he beats the [ __ ] out of
you
he never rubs it is very I mean he was
very gracious because he [ __ ] the
first time just literally made Bisbing
look like he was in a different weight
class yeah him with one arm very
gracious Australia very gracious about
it so he's a [ __ ] b-boy guy even when
it be Weidman he was like very emotional
yeah for sure you have a staph infection
I gotta get my leg amputated and so I
have the belt he's gracious in victory
is easy
whereas Bisbing is the one with that
fight was the exact I was actually kind
of shocking I was like you know I'm not
shocked by Bisbing up well you know I'm
so well but if you watch his career I
mean you spit on a coach and flip the
guy off what about Jorge Rivera
apologize apologize yeah I mean it's
just but he gets so emotional is he
takes it personal that's a lot those
guys get motivated and fight for him for
real like yeah lucky if he's he's any
he's definitely very authentic Michael
Bisping so you can like people yeah yeah
he is you can't expect everyone to be
goody two-shoes and no I love it's the
fight he's giving your Romero figure
hike died and yours like come on he's
sitting there why I love you Michael
it's not terribly great what why do you
why do you love me yo because I why what
do i sexual relations with you obviously
let's fight let's do it I love you but
in a very real way what like what why
don't we just settle this in the Octagon
for sure but also afterwards maybe we
caught up just a little bit just a
little bit the true Frank yo Romero um
that was his for the win do you think
Whitaker is there to stage you think
Whitaker is what's working good dude
what you're calling that well he's out
for a while so you got busy yeah Bisping
G I think he he beats Bisping and
Bisping retires after that thing but
well actually he I actually don't know
who's gonna win the Bisping GSP fight
the fight doesn't nothing I know it does
I love both no it does not actually just
don't care I don't know like a fake
match okay but just for for your for
like the percentage of your listeners
that do care because it's it's just a
conversation to have like a very real
conversation what happens break it down
uh it's tough to pull out hold on just
because you're you big brown break down
yeah go go I think with GSP got being
gone for four years is such a calculated
fighter
I think it's me here it's not exciting
fight I think it's him sticking behind
his jab kind of outpoint sparring
Bisbing you think that keep it personal
you don't think that he who tries to
stay behind the jab for a long time and
then Molly Jake Shields yeah all Oh Jake
Shields all ah you know these other guys
that he's fought before I think he's
staying behind his jab and then
eventually gets Bisbing down the ground
you think he's tough to take down I know
his jab is is gets the better of class
but what a world class Freddie Roach but
hold on a second this being stand-up is
not to be messed with
I think I used to think he was the best
striker in the middleweight division for
a time this was fair this was before yo
Romero and all these people and not real
Romero this before Luke Rockhold vs.
technically he's high-level I mean right
look case as in as in highest level like
I mean who's the champion 2010 bit
Bisping like those are Anderson Silva
Desmond I understand he's gay that's
true okay so outside of Anderson
of I thought that he was great good
boxing and phenomenal take on offense
and stamina like his cardio is his best
asset and Anderson Silva just puts it
together in such a way that it's just
Michael Jackson just like well you don't
go like you know Anderson striking is
just stand up his hands are really major
he just plays the guitar and like yeah
sidekicks you here's the thing with
Anson though you say best of all time he
tested hot sure yeah there's no doubt
that everyone on back in the day no no
go yeah
against but that against Nikki yeah
that's right that's what I'm talking
about back in the day whether or not
even Sarah is not the way he fought was
like I don't care it's almost like the
way he fought
I don't know that steroids informed that
his ability to measure distance his I
mean his she was just so creative
I don't think steroids help you with
that explosive and I don't doubt that he
was doing steroids with everybody let me
tell you something I see your eyes I see
you're skeptical hippo eyes and I get it
can't say stories doesn't help you hey
no absolutely with your speed with your
recovery with your billing with
everything you know that guy that was
neo and the matrix against Forrest
Griffin yeah had Juicin yeah that was
hey remember that guy that took the belt
from Rich Franklin
how could juicing you know that guy that
front kicked V tours mask off yeah
that's allegedly sir there's no proof of
that but yeah that's a shirt you just
pay me like or just give me at least a
medium just don't be out of graze yeah
you only have it in orange bro or I know
all orange yeah it's [ __ ] I don't
know man don't MMA right now and the P
DS it's a [ __ ] bummer
yeah oh yeah hey so three title fights
at MSG though yeah [ __ ] it let's stop
talking about UFC what were you looking
at me to kind of Triple D I was gonna
say how many actors do you think on peds
oh that's my uh Tom Hardy in warrior
it's just a roll by roll kind of case
every um every boxing movie super Juicin
super super jeffrey superhero yeah
a juicy but also if you gotta lose what
I've had Brad Pitt Brad Pitt in there
that's Troy juice Ashley Brad Pitt in
Troy hun Jews but why did why wouldn't
you I was so good at this one cycle do
yeah why wouldn't you why wouldn't you
is right I want my super unless you're
afraid of it the way I am I'm afraid
this side effects wheat I'm like I'll go
bald I'll have acne and then I'll be
like the worst you will harden Emily
weird [ __ ] yeah oh and by the way that
human growth [ __ ] it's like I love
living and they like well I talked to
Aubree degre who's the leading like like
anti-aging scientists like he's working
on the seven ways that the human cell
breaks down he's like this really wild
guy we believe him like we can actually
live forever and so he I said what about
I was a young Rory he's no he's a high
level no I mean the idea is that that
there's a human cell from breaking down
and he's he's a like a cutting-edge
scientists like this wild dude bring up
Aubrey de Grey and take a look at what
he looks like he's just wild guy but
meanwhile he said like I said what about
he knows everything about all of the
endocrine system is everything what
about human growth hormone it goes well
I mean you know I mean I think it's fine
as long as you don't have any
predisposition to uh they bought in cash
start a story with he has the most
insane ten Lord of the Rings be that's
nervous I'm out no no he's a pretty like
I'm out he's a brilliant side you were
so pretty look like that he's weird he's
a baby no he's on the spectrum he's just
weird
oh but he was also he looks like
Rasputin yeah news also playing Jean
Valjean in that picture after he gets
out of jail for twenty years
yeah he's the weird as I thought
breaking news like literally everyone on
a basic level knows HGH it grows every
right if can't sell there right so if
you hear guy just woke up on a subway
and was like you guys want to hear about
some HGH
here's some obvious things really god
you're not driving just google image
search
Aubrey de Grey Aubrey there's a live you
re one I go ah Breda great what diet are
you want let me go opposite right you
look like [ __ ] who's on that die where
he doesn't eat anything when you talk to
him though he's so like level-headed and
then you see him you're like you look
like like the man who's warning about
the apocalypse on the subway who looks
like he smells like olives I don't I
don't want to pay speaking of somebody
who is kind of making headlines bread
lines is Jim Carrey no but I got no idea
cuz I got a story about it but please
okay so the suffering that huh bring the
I you up love it guys I know that he's
definitely goes in hard but I heroes
icons how is it that I love it because
we don't matter we don't matter
oh he's great in the end of the Truman
Show I've run in to Jim Carrey tell me
or is it sure you're wandering the
streets you need a date to the party
with them that was rude
loving it so far meaningless thing that
I could find come to he's so right by
the way he goes too far but he's so
right I mean you got to admit it's
completely meaningless like now he's
being slightly me and she's working it's
like I Cron's
what do you do believe in icons I
believe in personalities I don't believe
that you exist
this way you win now he clearly does a
lot of ayahuasca tea you don't believe
certain icons have the power to make
change to think differently to be bold
to inspire other artists which is a good
point of course she does a good foot he
just does he just doesn't think any of
these people are worth a [ __ ] damn
and here's ayahuasca tea kicking in
here's the Mali he took kind of speak
newest young the red s that you wear on
your chest that makes bullets bounce
lead her now he's going from a to L here
okay that might make sense
now you talked about tetrahedrons coming
up really dressed up for the occasion
you look good she's good at a point good
she's holding a bunch of tetrahedrons
food actually is relevant that's not
that here's the thing it's not our world
nobody don't matter we don't matter okay
now conversely she held her own John did
great she did great she also provoked
him in the very beginning now he also
there's something that's far too long to
play on a low volume for your listeners
but it's six minutes long and we're not
gonna watch it but they have rewind
stuff no this is um him about his
painting and all the paintings and how
it's great it's amazing he's operating
on a different wavelength and he's a
true artist that will make him crazy
it's kinda could you is that my problem
with this is this he was at Montreux
he's at the Montreux Comedy Festival and
he went off on this tangent and and you
know Eric Griffin was like well but Jim
you know you're really good at comedy
and in fact you might be one of the best
ever he's a genius and an arrogant so
hard to get there know what man Eric was
like and Jim started saying some seven
people started laughing and he goes you
can't help but be funny dude look and it
seems to end the what I take away I was
i watch him and I've watched him give
these speeches he's having an
existential crisis so what happened was
he got to the top he's also a
manic-depressive he got to the top and
he realized this isn't the I'm at the
top of the wall I don't like the view
wrong wall of stuff you hear about was
Fame okay I was a this for like what
I'll tell you what you're making since
your three
oh you know it's all about love or it's
all about yeah dude
I [ __ ] know don't tell me about like
what you're really good at and what made
you powerful was the fact you made me
laugh and you were original and you
worked so hard of those characters and
we were like wowed and awed that's where
you provide inspiration believe it he
said he lost himself in all those kids
yeah that's okay I know people there's
an actor's ramblings of a madman
he's not profound he's not deep Oh in a
way I feel like these dude look at this
art it's [ __ ] it's a real art in my
damn house he's a real so do art but but
when you get into these self-help thing
to me is so hostile I just I resent it a
little bit what I don't think it's
helpful well what I love about the other
thing I mean look at that [ __ ] look at
his Jesus painting but when you when
when when you watch this and you get to
know this side of Jim Carrey you
actually respect him and I like this
because this is very personal to him now
when he tries to like impart his slight
bitterness on to other people that is
rude you know what I mean when he says
this doesn't matter and it's like well
you're here and you don't know I list
and you actually dressed up literally
got fit for that just don't done you
might cry you might be promoting a film
and you might be like oh yeah yeah but
he might have had to go you know the
studio's making him go to he was out of
a Mason yeah he was recently at a film
festival in Italy so he probably was
just doing something very high art and
now know what sometimes you're when guys
were that talented they're gonna be a
little batshit crazy I'm supposedly I
feel like that's what we got want my
artist a little crazy I feel like he had
a bit of a crisis sort of them it's sort
of a nervous breakdown that's he didn't
do that's a stupid fan art that's just
hey that's just never look at him as the
ultimate warrior II just never paints
himself yeah yeah I definitely not oh
look at the one where he made himself as
a caricature as Lloyd and Dahmer know
that's not really not what about that
one down there with the II sort of
deconstructed face on no he doesn't
paint anything no that's from a movie
that's from yes man I'm sorry that's
from our Lyle area or the paint yeah I
mean the tape yeah I don't know man it's
it's a strange place for him to be in
head if you watch his comedians in cars
getting coffee he's just insane he's
just good it's gonna episode though
episode it's phenomenal but like he like
line lines over there likes be hey it's
like just open the gate Jim but that's
him yeah that's it that's why you love
that is that's it that's really good
yeah I don't know I mean you know yeah I
don't know I think he's a guy who's
having an existential crisis he's having
like this long drawn-out midlife
existential breakdown he had a great
interview on Howard Stern - he likes -
they're saying you haven't anything - I
guess I just like to disappear for like
two or three years man and take a break
from hiyo and I'll jump back in that's
like to do people man there's this guy
Tom halls who played Amadeus Amadeus
so Tom quit acting Tom produced Spring
Awakening actually a way more strung out
like no not strung out but just older
just like you'd be like oh god you're
like you don't act anymore and I talked
to him about it he's like dude I've made
myself crazy like I when I put Amadeus
I'd lock myself in a room for six months
and learned how to play piano the way my
source is so good he wasn't Dominic in
Eugene remember was great which was out
shadowed by Rain Man he's like very
similar just a Tomic Andy James crazy he
he Ted he's like dude I it almost killed
me I mean he did a lot of drugs and I
mean it's did it's a weird thing this
thing that we do why I would do it I
feel like a lot of those people are
already manic depressives are a little
crazy and then what happens is they
would be that way of in anything they
chose just going on about the but I
don't think that the work I don't think
the work of acting or the work of Armijo
water is so crazy I think in fact it's
the opposite I think when do you stop
doing what you're supposed to do and you
stop giving yourself that outlet that's
where you run into trouble right stop
being creative I mean Stephen King on on
in his book on writing talks about this
he goes there's this misnomer or this
idea that creative people do drugs and
we're crazy no there are really creative
people like me who had a substance abuse
problem it's so - that's really what
it's about it's like all the white
musicians of the 60s and 70s Janis
Joplin Jim Morrison Hendrix for that
matter who
whose heroes were were that were the
blues and jazz musicians of the 40s and
the 50s and the 30s who got into drugs
and Billie Holiday and they wanted to be
like them so they subscribed to that
lifestyle yeah they gave themselves as a
drug problem because it's deep because
it's different because to suffer is
there was a romance to it but at the end
of the day it's [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
and when I hear Jim Carrey talk about
this he gives his point of view on the
world and this is all meaningless
that's cool dude but it's not
meaningless and I disagree with you
because I have children I have a very
fulfilled life I work really hard at my
stand-up and I love what I'm doing right
now so
speak for yourself my friend but you
know me I'm fine I find a great deal of
joy and accomplishment does it have oh I
know I have a really nice house dude do
I have a nice house I have a lot of
money okay I know that that's not I know
that's not the end I Drive a Tesla I
know that doesn't right right and my
house is nicer and like the things I see
that's not that's just more square
footage in a bigger pool and a hot tub
Oh see I feel you turn it on from my
phone right now to show you the point I
think the point is that I've done a
really great year missing the whole idea
damn it
right well no I actually agree to you to
an extent but I think that like life is
all about a balance of all this stuff I
think we're seeing a weird when you're
at a CDF a fashion event that it is
slightly meaningless that we all just
got dressed up these downs just stare at
each other and it's all about the
picture I know that but you take that
with a grain of salt and guess what you
signed up for another boy you're there
who's there yeah and that's why Hillary
Swank goes to McDonald's after she wins
her Oscar people like that's just the
most quirky or like no because that's
kind of what you want to do after that
that's right I want to just do the
opposite of what you just did sometimes
it's nice to celebrate sometimes nice to
be recognized yeah your celebration but
it you don't want to you don't want to
embrace it completely and let it find
you but we all know that don't let money
to find you don't let the status in vain
no we all agree with that sure you
everybody loves yeah things life
it's jumped in money grenade our [ __ ]
bro pay money life
Renda now yeah I'm more on that I think
in a grander scheme to take it out of
like our business and the whole actory
kind of talk I think that in life and
this is just like weird but I've been
thinking a lot about it I mean we this
all could we create we're all gonna die
one day what is all this [ __ ] no no
but I want to you know we we could I I
think that I think that like okay it's
like with act and I just what tried to
take it bigger and I'm gonna go right to
acting but I think that like what I like
to try to do when I play roles
especially more compelling roles is to
do a bunch of preparation and to know my
[ __ ] and to know who this person is
inside and out understand the lines
enough to perform them and then throw it
all the way and I think like in life
it's important to do that kind of stuff
to take inventory of what you're doing
but also know that it does it's it's too
it's too complex to say it means nothing
it means something but it doesn't mean
as much as a lot of people make it mean
so what he's trying to say there is like
hey this is all ridiculous this we're
not actually at a big event I'm standing
in front of a couple pieces of plywood
and a backdrop it's not that bad you've
shown lights on it and this is gonna go
viral and this can get all know that
including the people that are clicking
on it a lot of times I don't think they
could imagine people doing ayahuasca you
know painting never leaving his house
finally they're like Jim you got a shape
that you're gonna go to this thing and
he shaves and how he looks like that and
then someone comes over to his hotel
room and like the mask tray he literally
looks like the mask we a wooden masks
have raised it's in our life in our day
where we just want to be shallow where
we want to smoke weed and watch a silly
movie or when we want to flip through
Instagram then we have moments aren't
day when we want to connect in an
intimate way we were super wrinkly shirt
you're being superficial I want to
achieve something we want to get you
something like an ironing fifty-year-old
you guys missing my point Dan travel
steamers are agreed and I'll tell you
why no guys it takes but again it takes
a warm hand your wife's face will you
walk the house wrestling well now you're
talking my language
yeah that's an excuse to take a hand of
my wife
these are sleeping that out I didn't and
I
you were gonna give me a heart attack I
was sitting in my thing and I even was
it balled up it was qualify it was
balled around I didn't literally texted
me 45 minutes before I got here and I
was in boxers and Hatton brushed my
teeth yet figured it out right wearing a
nice steamed shirt can I'm not mad at
your upper thighs you got some strength
there I've been riding my bike around
New York City
non-stop thank you for noticing out
there I it's been on September and I'm
sure parts of October are perfect my
brother has a bunch of bikes and he gave
me one and I just literally ride
everywhere just recorded a cartoon take
my bike tie it up I might start doing
deliveries but you guys think yeah that
like a pose yeah I like it a little
postmates I'll just get your order wrong
every time and try to throw the food at
you and be out before you can decide you
did yes that dressing on that you didn't
even have any dressing okay I'll have my
dry salad only crazy come post mates
instead of going to red carpets freaking
out your stoop oast mates anybody here
do post mates I do it all the time I do
it all they suck kind of they're not
great they're liars
there's no way to add to your order like
there's no I literally was ordering
something from them yesterday and and
was like no and I want that rustic
chicken soup damn it let me add it I
contacted the guy I went through seven
channels of hell and he's like he's
already they're picking on my order
going well you could do is cancel this
order of all the food that I had for a
house full of people and then reorder it
again toss it on there bro guys I want
to talk more about my minutiae of my day
yesterday detail guys have a Waterpik
man that's what can I ask you guys it's
a good way to floss can I ask you guys a
question about women for a second the
women in your life and this is all out
of to respect do you find that women
tend to like to talk a little bit more
about the minutiae of their day and is
that maybe is that a little tough
sometimes to do I don't I'll just be I'm
being hypothetical
well I what I don't like to do is do a
rebound breakdown of my day yeah yeah
went through it yeah well to be honest
my wife actually keeps it rich she's
like we are we're the same because we
just check out one more go
like how was it it was great I was there
for 14 hours oh did you do the scene 80
times Oh were you good in a lot of them
yeah okay do you kind of also want to
get food now and watch some kind of
anymore yeah I'll tell you one thing my
mother who I loved dearly I recently
started making her aware of certain
things that she does and she's critical
revelation to her I was like mom do you
know you tell me about food from times
that like from like nights before in
gross detail I tried doing with my dad
yeah it doesn't work oh now I say it
every time I just like widen my eyes and
she goes oh my god I'm doing it but
seriously the salmon was so lean my
mother [ __ ] do they do them all the time
dude I try to do it with my mother where
I said you would have loved for what I
don't whenever situation I thought of at
it because they had wine there they had
all these different comments my mom
that's called a wine list everyone has
one yeah yeah my dad you know don't eat
what is that about what she probably is
something in my area well my dad will
tell me about things in my area that
I've been to and he says the he'll be
like that's a burger place I'm like
eight there last night it's Chinese food
yeah you know it'll be like if you ever
need a shirt you should go in that place
where there's extra place over here yeah
it's what parents do man yeah I'd like
to like take care of you still you know
they like to my dad still wants to be
like assert himself like I've been there
well you just want you even with sports
there's just any so long bat stuff and
I'm like that's a tough one especially
for me or my brother my brother knows
more than but someone tries to tell you
about something about something you do
also that's how my dad doesn't have no
problem my dad my mother will find
what's wrong or dangerous in every
situation and only harp on that and then
if she's not finding out what's wrong or
dangerous she will always bring up how
all of her friends everybody she knows
are essentially dying or not doing well
and I said I said you you just you have
to wherever you I said yeah I said I
said look you you are walking around
asking what's tragic
wrong or dangerous about everything
that's literally the question over and
over again and so you have nothing
you're you're you're when I drove with
you for an hour and you basically made
me sad stressed and worried about
everything
I said can you please can you please not
warn me about something that's dangerous
can you please ask yourself what's good
about this
we're in Utah the view is expect Acula
everybody's healthy kids are doing great
she's doing and I'm like can you not
keep waiting for the other you know what
I love about what's right about this
situation Bryan was like we just really
quickly digress about like the women in
our lives and you're like yeah I just
got engaged I'm like yeah I've just
celebrated my first year anniversary
couldn't be happier I love my wife
you're like cool because here's the deal
with my wife I mean what the nagging and
okay so yesterday I took the trash it's
like oh I see what happened I tried I
tried to tell my dad like and we're dead
I'm like dad do you realize all you talk
about is food my dad's super competition
like mean he goes why I could talk about
my job with computer science and program
you guys to understand [ __ ] about the
food see my parents got blessed it's not
that they run out of things to say but
they have their routine they have their
stories they have their experiences and
they're very fond of them and a lot of
that has taken place in the past when we
were all in you know in the house and
all you know she's who dresses up yeah
yeah just the Hindman look I know I said
a pee juice for the little guy it was
too and we've told you get me I said
because I get it
not my mom we went to Disney World but
the small where I get it well my dad
they just went to Italy so I'm super
stoked about the food out there what I
love is the next three years you were
told you better had something to say I
was in Italy and like what and then
they're like well you know we were there
I'm like I know but that was 30 years
ago I don't know if they had the same
rest I think that's the one we went to
well it's Italy my dad I don't think you
went to the one mile because I was on
the water it's Capri Italy it's all on
the wall yeah it was like in a cliff
I've been there here's the difference
here's the difference between the one
you went to mine came out two years ago
my dad don't one-upper so what operas
are tough ooh this was rough man
so when I got my my Porsche GTS my dad
cz goes uh GTS I mean yeah that's the
you know every option well I'll go
through yeah that's cool my buddy has
gt3 and I went what is my friend at the
gym is
gt3s two of them his horn ones like this
was dt3
and as bigger rims and then he has or
gd3 that's white in green there's only
500 min the world on it very very cool I
yeah this isn't GT there are better car
and I don't know your friends so yeah so
don't give a [ __ ] do you still want to
FaceTime so I could show you the car or
reason a person yeah this is the murders
yeah I see you're showing him the car
yeah that's that's tough friend of GTV
yeah that's the it depends what you
liked it's only one better than this
it's better when I talk to my dad I talk
to my father
hard no it's not that it's hard it's
just they love it they they they they
appreciate it so much but they just they
know I think still want to be liked but
I still kept you alive for a lot of
years if I talked to my father and I'll
ask him point a question on whether it's
politics or something and he'll give me
sort of a deep answer and then if I if I
start talking about anything that hasn't
got a lot of meaning if God forbid I
talk about my dear something he'll he
suffers no fools he'll just go alright
I've enjoyed this quality time the golf
course and it's [ __ ] great guys see
what I I'm trying to do these days I
like I took my dad to a mech game the
other day and I know they suck but we
went the hole on the field and
everything he's a lifelong fan and we
you know free liquor of course we just
were slamming it was so fun and it was
great to see his guard down because I
don't know about your pops but like it
sounds like he it's hard for him to get
his guard down with you and I think that
that that that happens a lot with
fathers to alpha male can you get out
your phone and shows pictures your
family so I can stand my eyes out do you
can you do that why should we go some
current events gen oh my god I actually
have the picture of my soccer you know
no okay I know no he was well here's
man's kid going sippy cup videos bikini
between hot here's my whole family at my
bar mitzva no no that's a lot
Oh hold on before you commence chin
what's up with your [ __ ] dating life
also did you get to email a fellow agent
man sent me I did you read that just do
drop some knowledge on us really chance
really I'll just read it what Brian you
read it you're good chin is part of an
overall phenomenon against among East
Asian males currently that are not very
sexually active or not involved in
dating either reproduction rates in East
Asia have fallen off dramatically and
there are many single males I'm of
Japanese descent myself and it's just a
fact that we Asians are not big dick
bandits like Brian and Brennan who need
to bust frequently and furious I'm like
I love this guy obviously thus it is
hard to understand the mentality of a B
DB justice it is hard to for a B DB to
understand us but this is one of the few
stereotypes you week you can joke about
without a fierce backlash yet true
nonetheless and alas it is further proof
that races when you exclude outliers and
mixed-race people are not created the
same in today's world we are fortunate I
these differences
you can't state even state statistical
facts otherwise you are a racist that is
why there is a strong backlash from the
far-right recently because we are forced
to live in denial if we really are all
equal let's make an all-asian NFL team
and see how poor manufacturer
electronics in Africa and see how that
goes
try and coach chin and how to be a big
dick bandit and see how that goes there
are reasons there are certain patterns
when it comes to race we are basically
the same but not exactly the same god
damn that [ __ ] he he is a great
he is a [ __ ] uh yeah he's a get
rooted gangster thing it makes him good
points I told you even last night I was
like hey this guy's actually like a
well-rounded thinker I got his email
address why don't we just read that so
it's basically gets backlash yeah idiots
um is that kind of true chin yeah we're
just different then apparently so you
got ground Korean cultures we're trying
to trying to fit a triangle a square
circle
yet to big dick bandits I'm learning
this in learning from the best or the
worst depending the worst it might not
be a fit for you know yep so what was
your guy's life we bust frequently and
furiously yeah you go make my sandwich
oh really because I thought it was
welcome thing before it ever happens I
don't look at look at how I'm thumbing
off you're welcome to [ __ ] anymore your
area go get it on the floor don't know
how this really works but I got so two
matches on a 1-1 like on tinder and one
match on tinder yeah okay that was
yesterday and then last night I got they
rescinded no not a bumble match I'm
good-looking the girl has to like can we
see him chin can give us your first oh
hold on hold on do you maybe I'm the
last person to understand yeah what is
the bump what is bumble so bumbles like
a nap where the girls at home that's a
separate app but that was like on tinder
you got humble sambal yeah yes basically
men they beso women have the power in
their cuz you out nice oh say that's
just so you don't do anything you're
just like oh I think you do swipe on the
girls you like but it's up to them to
make them move on you
you can't meso whoever you're seeing
they've already approved you yeah that's
great oh no I know everyone you like if
they like you back then they have to
make a move so if you matched up with
them they have to make those you can't
do anything about it so Jim what's up
with these homes Rascher what end oh
Jesus man I know hey Brendon oh god no
that's offensive god damn it tell us
about your bumblebees but the girl
yesterday yeah turned out to be a robot
because it says like first her first
message was a smiley face with it I
think it said I want to make America
great again with you okay I'm looking
for sex buddy with a link
okay so all right so all right so that's
spam there's another like here I don't
know how to do this though so this is
like someone actually likes that's the
difference between liking and matches I
don't know I think that's a match right
yeah maybe they just see you and they
just press the like instead of have you
ever sung that's a real lazy one gonna
swipe I'll just but I'll show you this
mumbles happy
so basically nothing's happened no wait
hold on
well no wait don't fake a counter tinder
there's a match the tinder there's a
real like and then there's a bumble
there's actual girl rock the bumble the
people no no no I don't see this bumble
don't call her a bumble [ __ ] I didn't
say that Scott have you ever broken into
song when you're having your climax I
don't I don't discuss that sing in
climax and tell you don't let's focus on
chin for a second not you right now hey
Skylar do you oh my god I'm at the robot
no this isn't the robot oh when you
match with or like me through bumble I
still don't know how that works you got
a bumble what about the match on tinder
that I understand that I'm not a you yet
that's why I said I just I just did free
not interested can I ever tell you this
but here's my thing the tinder match you
guys match ups and now don't you open up
a like a dialog but that was the robot
so the match was match on tinder that
was a race you see I kept like on tinder
and I don't know how to open to like it
I look the last I listened to the
podcast there were no matches this looks
like it's a step up let's put this one
to bed we'll check back in because right
now you're in you're in BOTS land
you're a bot land there's a subtle match
kind of maybe we don't know let's let's
let's hold on a second I thought we
might have done this and I am a pretty
loyal listener I'll go ahead but I've
only listened to a couple in the last
year so here's my question you guys
should have Rappaport on again my ears
finally recovered [ __ ] best bro you
[ __ ] you can I just be here going in on
me
hattie because he won best guest and now
you're all you guys judge that no man's
judge 10 kill him
he was great don't put I know have you
got fan of the Year wrap in the rap hit
him up on Twitter see nah I don't just
let me let me just do raps think I'm a
[ __ ] Astin yeah you [ __ ] you I know
you're a [ __ ] New York guy you do
theater or some [ __ ] but I'm the [ __ ]
guest of the year I'm friends with all
these [ __ ] rappers I'm the loudest
[ __ ] person in the world so so loud
so one gear and he's gonna go in on me
you [ __ ] you probably have no [ __ ]
calluses on your hands you a [ __ ] you
you [ __ ] you know you you pretty boy
[ __ ] I know I know
he'll help you Hawks me out in
basketball and I'll show you what he'll
get you in a corner and just shove you
around don't do me a favor
don't toss away here's the thing about
Michael Rapaport he was one of my
favorite boyfriend's of Phebe on friends
and and and I led next to Paul Rudd now
because I'm the second coming up over
but um I like him Louis Pilate shots
taught to me by Glenn Holmes through
this to me don't worry Jeffries who's
given the sign of it don't fight don't
fight basketball of them cuz I know he
throw elbows he'd have an act off no rap
would come in at you and he'd be just
big and bony and shovey and he would
just he'd all New York Street just throw
a throw he'd hit you as I just reach one
in Brooklyn it doesn't matter you're you
were an artist listen me he would he
would right elbow you a [ __ ] Broadway
baby you yeah he didn't [ __ ] come in
here with you [ __ ] oh I hit mitts I
[ __ ] go left and right and I put her
on Instagram and he fights he I get it
he's a scrappy guy yeah maybe he take me
he's also seven hundred pounds more as a
[ __ ] might love each other though I
think we would love each other to be
honest with you but I have to talk [ __ ]
cuz I'm here and I'm sure it's just
[ __ ] I think the fans should vote I
think I should buy come on one more time
really lobbying for you shoot out the
fans vote though we should do a
scholarship
but your dad you're challenging wrapping
away physically and this is my back
episode I won we finally get Brian out
we'll do a co-host breakdown respectful
to me in my pot and I'll [ __ ] comment
I'll do a bunch of riffs and everyone be
like dude every time you sings and I'll
get more Twitter activity while Michael
Rapaport of like hate tweet me something
Jewish and then I know but it'll be like
[ __ ] Jew you're half a Jew either
good half you're you're right you're
Italian to it how damn it pizza bagels
you're not really Jewish actually
because your mom's a tie my mom is
Jewish my dad is Jewish it's you know so
we're not like I know what religion are
you Italian Jewish Muslim if your mom's
Jewish Italian was Italian
no I don't know about that bro maybe
you're lying you're not really a Jew
your dad's a Jew my mom's my mother I
know your mother is I don't know your
dad is bro he looks like Tony Soprano
understand thank you so here's the deal
my mom's mom is Jewish therefore it's
the mother well I'm a Jewish as [ __ ] bar
Mitzvahed bro ma'am I don't know bro you
know what to be honest with you I've
always saw I've seen a lot more Italian
female rabbi at my wedding oh wow yeah I
I crushed the cup did the whole thing
Mazel Tov did the hora had six-gun and
Chris Weidman lifting me up on my horror
I picked them out and they were being
[ __ ] because they were trying to hit
my heads into the limo John was in there
it was through the roof he's a bigger
better fight fighter dick rather than I
am Rand's with hansiundcaro who put me
in an arm bar for Instagram yeah he
don't obsess obsess with their size and
doesn't watch videos on Instagram yeah
you are
i watch like brian the other day at
lunch is it's crazy man like cowboy
likes like everything I poke how many
times have you been to the ranch
what how many times you been to the
ranch Cowboys my buddy how many times he
likes my have you been to the lake on
the phone if you've been to the lake
okay and he gives me many pins a wall
moccasins cowboy gives me Bob he doesn't
though yes he does was left uh he gave
me a one-hour lesson dude that's what
cowboy does he chose he's my kid all
wrong
you're throwing elbows wrong and he
shows you the little one too with the
high kick coming after all it's his
dreamy secret cheese drill weight event
don't say that he has a generic drill
for all right so cowboy you're obviously
like me more you'd like Tom no he
doesn't he likes me he likes all of my
things I just don't see them cuz I have
over a million followers very confused
eating with me man you probably won't
tell me what you stuff the difference is
that I'm not competing I'm winning
whenever so whenever some more
critically Scott whenever a cowboy and
head so like my videos I'm always like
he and so likes my brothers and now he
doesn't man it does you know I'm have to
cut this off to feel sick from both this
talk all right let's get a current
events for the matter it's getting the
current offense I'm pissed off right now
what do you got chin alright [ __ ] Ted
Cruz's tweet from his official Twitter
account like the porn video or post did
you do you guys could be that could be
we go down no he actually made us no you
can go to see what people liked right
here you could see like and what's he
supposes rebuttal would he say he just
said it was a staffing error
oh one of the staffers but then Jimmy
Kimmel made fun of him said that maybe
was you like some people think it was M
but then yeah what about maybe was you
what about definitely was you more than
likely its you scroll up swim put my mom
and takers is jacking off on 9/11 doing
why would he do that I would be like he
might then what happen he didn't like it
so he so there's a lot of people in the
staff have access to that account so
that's what happened
well should they are lie to be on so
who's going on Ted Cruz's account unless
if they're trying because it don't work
it's a work account it's a work it was
actually accessible to an it that's a
fact it was it's an entire office
supposed to that's a fact the woman from
the video looks like his they look
identical I understand they're wearing
this same outfit doubt he would like it
I also I I wouldn't be surprised this is
the here's the thing he's old as [ __ ]
and doesn't realize how social media
offend a fan until those did that's true
he defended abandoned
[ __ ] I see the details of that I
don't know I don't like that guy but I
don't know a lot of time to like like
when Troy Aikman got caught he thought
he was sending a DM but it's just
sending a tweet to sidepiece I mean it's
like these older guys just [ __ ] up
parties for you to figure out now
imagine Ted Cruz yes it's like was like
I'll get on here well I get that yes
please I simply have logged on to this
account and I'm looking at this oh
that's a wonderful sexual image I'm
gonna like idea I'll like that so it
goes in my feet elevator like he doesn't
know Ted Cruz's book tells I didn't read
it but he was talking about and he tells
the story about how Sandra Day O'Connor
the Supreme Court justice he dad to
watch hardcore porn to make a ruling so
he's in there with he's 26 years of
Clark the the great Sandra Day O'Connor
like you know a [ __ ] icon of feminism
is there and then and then like some
other like clerks is up and they're
watching they had to watch like just
just get tough filthy I'm dropping loads
and and sanitaire Connor went and she
goes just goes and defends a ban on
dildos huh no it's the force so very
conservative man yeah as a conservative
although in other words he's trying to
control people him trying to yeah appeal
to his base somehow he doesn't really
know you don't like dildos I don't
support them but very religious
Christian a very Christian man alright I
was thinking my Ted Cruz impression
nobody yeah this is this actually
happened in London a dudes dog home this
guy was a drug dealer dude I get worried
about this because my mum redoubt cuz
listeners won't know what the [ __ ] don't
let them guess though I like good kid
alright so BBC was at this guy's house
filming a documentary about drugs and he
was he just did some cocaine himself
this guy and he sort of the cocaine then
had like an epileptic seizure oh so he
laid down his dog freaked out bit his
neck bit his face and then ended up
killing him and then they tested the dog
later
the dog had like eight times the amount
of cocaine and morphine in his system
that if there's like a drunk driving or
drug driving long
was it sounds like Staffordshire -
pitbull bull terrier I've been keeping
the drugs in the dogs [ __ ] and the
drugs the bag broke or something so they
think the dog was affected by that stuff
freaked out - yeah I know what happened
here look at that dog no it's not you it
was they were doing that oh they do that
they were doing that in Baltimore they
were doing I know but not here so here's
he was filming a documentary on drug
dealers the guy's a drug dealer you know
give me like in this house like there's
drugs my dog's [ __ ] well know if he
said his time drugs on the street anyway
so they're not drug dealer they're doing
a documentary on drugs dogs are I know
where I'll be hurt really well you're
not gonna go into a pit bulls [ __ ]
no cops dirty drug maps it was a
document on drug maps in Britain and the
guy had epilepsy trying the dog just bit
his [ __ ] neck that's amazing
Game of Thrones [ __ ] questions man
that's like they won't let me horrible
way to go man gets the line this woman
who used to work in this place she goes
my dog killed a guy and I go what she
goes well we had an orange tree and a
guy decided to jump into my backyard
she used to work at one of the studios
waste chute this TV show because I'm an
actor and she goes thank God yeah he
tried to steal it tried to steal some
oranges and my Rottweiler got a hold of
his neck and bit him in the front than
that can kill him right there and do
their killing machines if you don't
train them right yeah they're
[ __ ] how's your dog doing good
good yeah great oh so smart gettin that
[ __ ] trained on kind of coming in your
house nope I don't know I like your
faces boys do you guys uh pudy pie
PewDiePie
he's the number one YouTube guy in the
world Oh YouTube celebrities I love them
well Chuck I think you'll love this
though so he oh he wears stupid-ass cat
ears that's it well here's his response
let's hear it maybe so big watch this so
he's made some like bad decisions as far
as controversy he said something like
anti-semitic stuff before but as in
comedy he's doing it like a nick in a
comical way but sounds hilarious he's a
comic
he's like a YouTube comic yeah and he's
a person in his bedroom
it has a webcam and some idiots are like
this described like yes 55 million
subscribers so he says the n-word dares
and now he's like he messed up so many
times I'm just an idiot I don't know
what I was doing so I want you guys to
hear how he's John Jones should take
notes
let's hear video he's a video source
which or twitch yeah oh he's just time
so have you ever said it jokingly that
way I'll know any what happens he
off-camera he that's in his vocabulary
yeah and it was his reaction to use it
when he's [ __ ] up that's how that
happened I mean and comment why does and
I am GG e oh yeah hard auto race that
was a hard R on that's not like the cool
rap white boy in the suburbs
yeah you can't it's ninja yeah he's like
oh man what an injury yeah like oh oh
KKK ads ever he's using it the way you
liked it for shock value for themself
and his friends like yeah you know like
a [ __ ] and that's not good enough so
now I gotta say the other word I think
it's in this vocab word cuz that was his
go-to yeah hmm
if he stopped his toys I would assume he
says similar stuff exactly I don't know
anyone that says it that way though that
I don't know it makes my racism probably
not it's like you know you're gonna take
some meat even your friends joke around
I love that we're giving this guy more
press he seems I don't need to he's
already famous yeah
listening subscribers a lot of this this
is just what I love to watch man drops
oh this poor guy did what he's proposing
those girl oh no breaks my heart oh no
I'm gonna laugh I know
Oh what no it's gonna it's gonna happen
she's laughing at oh there's no dock
jump your big ass over that bridge Jude
these are both in shape no cookie Ike's
come what's on the ceiling Brendan what
is that ah ceiling hey to be honest
deserves how much oh look at everyone
now all
well they found it no they didn't find
it oh no a lot they did a GoFundMe page
I'm just gonna say let's start a
GoFundMe for him but they didn't make
much money I don't think how much was
the ring there's a $3,000 he won Dom
dude this link I'll tweet it out I feel
terrible for this 261 he's like I got it
yeah I think it's a sign from God
I probably shouldn't get married I have
to think dude you'll see man like
there's those things like nerve when you
walk down a runway or something you like
just don't trip right that's the thing
like with like a wedding or like just
don't fall or just don't don't [ __ ] and
I was on a I was on a winery I was like
I had I went my ring bearer was my dog
and we liked hi to him we tied the real
things I thought we were gonna do the
old western switch where I just have him
the whole time but like my wife
legitimately tied it to him very well
but we didn't discuss how she was gonna
tie it and I was just like it was just
there was a moment where like I was like
because I mean he could have just ran
off and then the bag could have just
fallen off and taken by a big it's just
like any delay in the ceremony - it's
like you don't want it worked out my dog
do you have a professional heaping me he
hit his mark well he's a puggle this
latest man dude so for those who are
watching perform well under pressure
listen I [ __ ] dude it's scary because I
don't know how you proposed your girl if
it was like super chiller whatever but
like there's there's definitely a very
surreal feeling and you know that was
feelings where you don't even feel like
you're in charge of your motor humming
hey bro didn't happen to me but he says
it either with this guy I could speak
for him - he's not saying anything but I
promise he wasn't nervous at all so
don't we're right by the ocean I wasn't
like god I hope this don't love us I
mean we're we're macho guys were we're
alpha we're apex out but how many
pirouettes did you do because I did
three now here's the thing I did it
whittling it on my finger vertically now
that's against Kauai stuck the landing
it landed in the palm of my hand that I
said give me Mary I don't find it though
yeah that's a river that's what I River
man no one has googa googa goggles so
that's just and also if that things are
streaming yeah boy it's hurricane season
I don't know if these birds
crocodiles are or adders it's not just
all those people in evening Plumas just
so ashamed what else you got to in $260
Jesus Christ that's terrible if I saved
that money Springs Missouri it's this
campaign is complete money their goal we
hit it they didn't hit there oh they
didn't okay I mean unless if he's like
yeah I got that guy's jeweler's $261
pretty cool this covers it yeah it's a
chocolate diamond I saw it out into the
computer by the way somebody get a mask
you're not gonna see I got one of those
slippery rings looking with their with
their shitty sweat they're just not
really the Hobby an old top like I'm
gonna get wet yeah actually some old
sona's dog not one big dude he's like
yeah he can't hold his breath he he
panics underwater he's looking for the
rim Allah clean open its binary looked
like they were
let's get that snapping turtle the shirt
on Jimmy is a walk in his hand on his
head just like he didn't even get in
himself god it's you know what I would
I'm sure a lot more people would have
donated if he was in that water with
them just looking like a putz a Soros
Soros [ __ ] Bangalore oh my god that's
all you know street vendors that's a
hotdog
oh this breaks my heart I saw this is
gonna make how do you see this the
officer just so he stops him takes his
money
why dude I can't watch there's no permit
when they've set so he has no permit to
do this he's crying and you know dude
that's what they live off of that they
need this yeah so the officer said I
have to do it this is part of the thing
because they didn't have a permit
apparently confiscating the cash is like
you know we called it for evidence I
drink that beer money for the cops dude
100%
play it you're doing just know hey you
know what the problem is they wear they
wear cameras look uh sad when it goes in
this wallet it's so sad you could oh
it's so sad
and this guy's filming it this student
who was just buying a hot dog like dude
go down the street look at her it's so
sad
I need that money he sees what he's
saying I want to give him money right
now right let's make him that cups
captain like thank God you did that man
yeah solid day at work what about the
public what about look at this cops just
doing his job you probably had a camera
on so he has to go by the book so he
can't is that not open he's good partner
there he's got to do it you know you
know what you gotta do you know it's
some of that net student that's filming
it his group of buddies has to do it at
Berkeley right now make a GoFundMe page
but make it make it to get here a permit
oh they did they did well they did it
and even have him get that permit and
become the most water hold up what
happened he made forty thousand over
three thousand and one of the first
things is gonna try it up like buy
permits for all of his buddies faucets
yeah and the front drop the ring gets
$200 he's a dumbass
sorry survival of the fittest bro we all
got a not good for him man how many hot
dogs are getting eaten by that guy
proposing to his wife zero
this guy is providing sustenance for a
whole group of drunk okay cool they
raised all that money that's crazy he's
a hero
not all superheroes wear capes let's
zoom in and people are nice aren't they
out there sure are it's Berkeley we need
a little bit more of this guy I want
this guy to be rich richer than Brian
not richer than me but like what you're
there you're like that's a good place
Skylar did poor guy man a poor guy I'm
sorry sixth grade yeah yeah he's not
sophomores friends
so it's good let's way more loot for him
imagine who's like [ __ ] my friends dude
you just get to MJ you have any current
events you want to do Oh
stolen yeah she did mention the Jim
Carrey one I like stole it I got a
dropping knowledge portal for it since
we're talking about racism a lot
probably want to hear my song I love I
do want to hear you cut it for all you
know your listeners don't know please
give us the song do it drop in knowledge
with the kid oh hey
nollie Twitter kid oh that's really yeah
but I didn't really lean into this much
you did you gave up be level effort yeah
I know you better than that I was aiming
your matter Brian I really wish I could
drop in knowledge can you teach me how
to do that yeah it's something that
could be taught it's not naturally given
to you Brian what's it on here that
anyone can sing with the right lessons
anyone I think anyone can whistle and on
the anyone I'm at the right lessons you
could always get better but there is a
bit of natural ability that goes in
there it's a balance the the dropping
the hose I had is interesting the idea
there is this idea we talk a lot about
racism and it's always kind of like
about you know the oppressed or the
marginalized or the voiceless and it's
typically like you know there's all
kinds of like this video I mean this
email you got was great about just for
the difference in races and that's all
we seem to talk about the truth is that
human beings have always been whether
it's racist or tribal we're very tribal
let me give you an example of the Dinka
in the Sudan
but Dinka in the Sudan I was having
first I was gonna say very black very
black people we don't hear about enough
Dinkas right there's a great deal of
racism or tribalism in Africa among
black on black for example like there is
everywhere with people in general the
Dinka the Dinka in Dinka means people
there know there there's sworn enemies
their sworn enemies the people that
they're always wearing with just down
the way are the nua do you know what nua
means in in in their language does it
mean it means original people it means
original people people are tribal we are
tribal everybody's travel you're not
going to stop racism tribalism by going
that's not fair
you've got to recognize that that's how
we are as people and that's how you
address it looks cubism written this Pro
racism rant hasn't been brought to you
by and that's Ryan Callen that's right
no I defended by and given by Brian
Brian cap no it's not defending anything
it said that that's how human beings are
chimpanzees Shem posies they found in
certain areas they will expand
their territory they'll take a bunch of
males they'll walk in a single-file line
along their area of territory and when
they come across other chimps from
another band they murder them murder
murder I saw that planet their children
and wives into it or their females into
it and that's how they annexed territory
we should be better you know the point
I'm making is that really when you when
you think you can cure something it
might be the wrong way to go about it
recognize that human beings are all
tribal we all have it in us and that
there are yeah I think it's a very sad
reality that that is there and that has
been exposed but I think we are making
progress and I think that when we we if
you try to find racism as everywhere
like if you try to find anything
everywhere you're gonna find it the
first thing we do as human beings with
our brains as we go I have a feeling
that feeling is let's just take race
though things are racist what we do is
we we accumulate data to support that
feeling because our feelings control our
thinking and so so they did a really
interesting study on [ __ ] breast
cancer with they dig a fake study they
said these women they go coffee can be
linked to breast cancer they had a
control group of women well what do you
think the the women who drank coffee
were trying to find flaws in that study
the first thing that is they go do I
have to believe this since I love coffee
so much mm-hmm so we'll immediately try
to find flaws in that day the people
that women that didn't drink coffee what
they do they went oh that's cool and
they went on so just be aware of how
your brain works
you will try to justify what you feel
and you'll try to not you'll try to
argue for something that goes against
how you feel be aware of that's how your
body works that's how you work yeah so
we talk a lot about these things like
racism and sexism and stuff oh they're
there we've made a lot of progress we
have but I think I don't know a man like
honestly I think that we're we're trying
I don't think that anyone's trying to
find racism right now I think it's out
there I mean if there are rallies in
places in gazebos Charlottesville Bund
man Charlotte's Ville was pretty rough
man yeah I think that like it just
because we're familiar with
doesn't mean we're looking for it I
think it's a really this is it this is
an interesting time you think we're
making progress
no but I really don't think that we're
making progress not a lot but I think
we're on the way to potentially here's
the thing I think that that this this
situation that we're dealing with right
now with our president with everything
is like make is holding up the mirror to
us and we're all looking at been like
okay so this is what America is right
now no hold on hold on but but we
remember the lot of those same voters
voted a black president two times in a
row we did have a back swing but was
that a racist thing or was that actually
people who were like you know what the
Democratic Party's not doing it for me
yeah I used to I voted Democrat my whole
life let me try this firebrand who's
really entertaining sure and I think I
think Bernie Sanders would probably
beaten from crazy though I think so but
I think the people wanted something very
like drastically different right and
that's why they went with Trump and I
understand how he got I understand now
how he got into office but I think that
it's now what we do with the next
election and the midterms that are very
important because I think we are we can
pick up progressively socially where
Obama left off by taking this back step
I think that I think that there is a
potential for in the next by the next
day because Trump's only go in one term
and I but I don't say that with any sort
of like guarantee because that wants one
- yeah I mean I've done [ __ ] he's done I
can't wait to see the movie
I'm just like what the [ __ ] was going on
man
but I think that like I think that it's
gonna be very interesting I think we
have the ability to become France where
we are celebrating in the streets in
2020 because there there is someone who
is offering what that that dimepiece
just inaudible or any of those people
and that guy in France not calm was
pretty assertive way more conservative
than our long national no marine lepen
yeah but our long was trying to tax the
rich 75% of their income he was the
total socialist right well the socialist
thing I don't really think is the thing
that we and that's not because like
because all get taxed a lot [ __ ] dad I
don't
[ __ ] anymore that's [ __ ] you can
have a lot of my money but what is tax
this taxation work when when the federal
government is re doling that money out
that's the one yeah exactly
historically there are better ways maybe
to go about doing it exactly that's all
I'm saying is so the whole point I'm
making is that we tend to brand these
problems we tend these complicated
problems and we go it's a racist problem
right problem is way more layered than
that and we are all human beings were
tribal over racist at times
we're complicated organisms and I think
when you brand large institutions or you
say we're racist or these voters are
racist you are labeling them in a very
simple way and you're actually not
getting to the root of the problem
you're certainly not getting an idea of
who you're real and what the real
problem an enemy is because so much of
the time you're thinking the same way
your enemy is you know the right and the
left the far right in the far left think
in very similar terms sure they think
very and very very in a very similar way
I should say oh they just think
different things you know right but it's
come to a place recently where I've
thought about that when Bush was in
office and I've always oh what's more
annoying that a radical conservative
maybe a radical liberal like I
understand all of those things but it's
come to a point where there's some real
ugliness going on there and there is
some real brutal manipulation go ahead
it's ever been any different though I
really know it's just we're seeing it
it's they're out of hiding well now yeah
cheeky sweet it they went to Lowe's yeah
you can tweet it but the Lowe's they're
like what are we thinking guys these
fishing poles or should we do these tiki
torches I'd like to I think we've made a
progress in a lot of ways I think
corporate America's made progress I
think caused it made progress I think I
think people are held accountable
because of social media and I think
people are less people are more aware
like if you were the same look to most
people hey the color of your skin
justifies what what how you well you can
do a job they go through there's no
science to support that most people kind
of that's permeated most of it but now
she comes down culture sure so so so so
maybe certain cultures like like ghetto
culture whether it's Latin white pill
Billy culture whether it's black culture
and southside of Chicago that might be
the culprit the culture the values
people grow up with the belief systems
you grow up with that's what has to be a
tact gotcha and for more of that mixed
mental arts.com my mic's Mentalist we
have any listeners left the hashtag
listeners no reason we talk about
important [ __ ] but I mean anyway that
was my dropping knowledge thank you very
much
dropping knowledge with the COO yeah
yeah dropping knowledge dropping
knowledge with the king can you can you
sign us off with the fire in the kid are
we done we're done that's cool looking
oh we're gonna end on that blast
it's been a long podcast my man quick
triple G Canelo you've done that already
I'm big brown breakdown so much list
with Tony Jeffries and listen Glen I
will I'm halfway right now sign us off
okay
this is the fighter and the kid in the
best guest of the year no well I was
like seeing us off no no you can't okay
welcome I'll sing you out you can't give
yourself that yet all right okay you
want me to sing it yeah okay do
something this is the fighter and the
kid and the guy that's obviously the
best guest of the year obviously know
what I feel like yes it's OneNote this
is that this is the probably be sharp no
because your this is the fight we're not
a green yet that you're that you're a
great and the most talented get together
and we'll have levi to do something like
a doo-wop okay you what he wants to do
well oh he wants just climb this has
been a blast get down together we could
talk about [ __ ] forever let's go to
lunch maybe do some dinner but maybe not
because I should be much thinner let's
go maybe I'll come back in December
Tambor's too soon but maybe I'll come
back never this is the fighter in the
kid we're out yes goddamn kids good
kitty